I do love being another idea it feels
like the most natural thing in my life
Jessica Simpson is a mom all over again
welcoming baby number three I had baby
fever but I didn't know that like I
really like neither thermometer I
thought about it but I didn't really
know that it could actually happen the
38 year old announced she and hubby Eric
Johnson were expecting again in
September posting these pics to
Instagram that's their six-year-old
daughter Maxwell and five-year-old son
ace participating in the gender-reveal
Simpson captioned this pic quote this
little baby girl will make us a family
of five we couldn't be happier to
announce this precious blessing of life
I already feel like I know her so well
like it's amazing how you feel like you
can't love anymore but somehow your
heart opens up and you have the capacity
to love deeper and stronger you know et
sat down with the fashion mogul in
October and she dished on their
expanding family you said you love to
practice yeah we definitely we always
love to practice and we actually weren't
practicing very much that much so I
don't understand we keep trying to like
this might be a miracle how are you
feeling I'm feeling good
third time's definitely harder I think
just the older you get it's a little bit
harder yeah but the kids are so excited
so that's what makes it so much fun like
because they're only 14 months apart so
they didn't get to experience the
excitement of each other but when I told
them that we were having a baby like I
know that they'll remember that for the
rest of their lives
you know cravings this time everything
every night crave everything yes it's
like with a girl I just want like
pop-tarts and cinnamon rolls and
cinnamon gummy bears and sour cherries
there's your style changed when I'm
pregnant I don't spend a lot of time on
myself I mean I put a lot of like like
belly butter on you know I spent a lot
of talk about my belly not so much
anywhere else so it's nice to be
pampered
do you wear sweats more often or do you
rock the heals a lot I know this time
can't rock the hills as much I don't I
don't know why my feet grew with every
pregnancy and I'm very sad if I have to
change my shoe closet again if I got
another half size up I'm gonna be really
upset but Maxwell will have a Maxwell in
this one we'll have all the shoes from
size 7 to 8 and a half you posted on
your instance Ori about helping with the
swelling by putting frozen french fries
on your ankles I think I was I would
think was frozen chicken yeah my feet
were so swollen I was like I mean what
do people do to like deflate yeah is
like ice so I didn't have an ice pack I
just use chicken what are your other
pregnancy packs or shortcuts or secrets
um I don't really know I kind of just
like go with it like immediately when I
found out I was pregnant it was like
stick the stomach out pop the hips out
and just just waddle just and a lot of
Tom that is my strut
[Music]